using the ones listed here so they're not Clifford operations poly operations on the other
hand are Clifford operations and specifically they can be implemented using sequences of hadam Art and Es
Gates so that's a simple way to define Clifford operations but it doesn't really explain why they're defined in
this way or what's special about this particular collection of gates here's the real reason that Clifford operations are defined like
this up to a global phase the ncub Clifford operations are precisely the unitary
operations that always transform poly operations into poly operations by conjugation to be more precise an nbit
unitary operation U is a Clifford operation up to a global phase Factor if and only if for every ncit poly
operation conjugating that poly operation by U gives us plus or minus one times some possibly different n
Cubit poly operation ation you can easily check that this property is true for hadamar Gates S
Gates and c not Gates so it necessarily holds for circuits built from these Gates what's harder to prove is that it
goes in the other direction which is that if we're given a particular nbit unitary operation U that satisfies this
property then it must be possible to implement it up to a global phase using just hadamard s and cot
Gates I won't go through the proof of that implication but it is true and you can look it up if you're
interested Clifford operations are not Universal for Quantum computation meaning that we can't run arbitrary
Quantum computations using just hadamard s and cot gates in fact for a given value of n there are only finitely many
n Cubit Clifford operations so it's a discrete set of operations so unlike a
universal set of quantum Gates we can't approximate arbitrary unitary operations to any desired level of accuracy and in
fact performing Clifford operations on standard basis States followed by standard basis measurements can't allow
us to perform computations that are outside of the reach of classical algorithms because we can efficiently simulate computations of this form
classically this fact is known as the goisman Kil theorem and the standard proof of that theorem is in some sense
based on the stabilizer formalism in particular the way that it works is that we can keep track of the way that Clifford operation transform poly
operations by conjugation which can be done efficiently and then infer from that what the computations do to
cubits so what does this have to do with stabilizer codes well a stabilizer code provides us
with a code space of a certain Dimension and we have the freedom to use that code space however we choose so nothing forces us to encode
cubits into that space in a specific way but it will always be possible ref form an encoding using a Clifford operation
as the encoder that's nice because Clifford operations are relatively simple compared with arbitrary unitary
operations there are ways to optimize their implementation which works along similar lines to the proof of the gsman
canil theorem and as a result circuits for implementing them never need to be all that
large in particular we can always perform an encoding using a Clifford operation that requires a little bit less than a quadratic number of gates
because that's actually true of every Clifford operation so the upshot is that for a given stabilizer code it's always
possible to encode cubits efficiently using that code and the mathematical tools that are useful for understanding Clifford operations can help with this
process for example here's an encoder for the 7 Cubit steam code it's a Clifford operation and as it turns out
this one doesn't even need S Gates for General stabilizer codes eror detection works in the following
way as before we'll assume that we have n Cubit stabilizer generators P1 through p r and we'll let e be an N Cubit poly
operation representing a hypothetical error on an encoding we're only considering poly
operations as Errors By the way because the discretization of Errors works in the same way for arbitrary stabilizer codes as it does for the 9 Cubit Shore
code the way that we check for errors is to measure each of the stabilizer generators as
observables there are R stabilizer generators so this means our outcomes where each one is a plus one or a minus
one or a binary value if you prefer to associate zero with plus one and one with minus one and these R outcomes
together form the syndrome just like we had for the three-bit repetition code when R was equal to
two in general there are three possible cases for the error e in terms of its detection and they are as follows first
it could be that e is in the stabilizer meaning that is possible to generate E from the stabilizer generators or
slightly more generally it could be that e is equivalent to a stabilizer element up to a global
phase in this case e isn't really an error at all because it has no effect in the code space other than to possibly
inject a global phase which doesn't have any effect so we don't need to worry at all about errors like this whatever
non-trivial action it might have happens outside of the code space so it doesn't concern
us much more of a concern is the possibility that e is not in the stabilizer even up to a global phase but
nevertheless it does commute with every single one of our stabilizer generators remember that it's the
anti-commutation of the error with a stabilizer generator that causes a minus one to appear somewhere in the syndrome
but that doesn't happen in this case so this is an error that actually does change vectors in the code space in some
non-al way and we know this because otherwise it would be proportional to a stabilizer element but it goes
undetected by the code so this is the bad case we have an error that may potentially be changing
whatever Quantum information we've encoded but the code is oblivious to this fact for example for the three-bit
repetition code XXX falls into this category and the last possibility is that the a e
anti-c commutes with at least one of the stabilizer generators and this means that the code detects this error because
we'll get a syndrome with at least one minus one somewhere in it which indicates that something is wrong and we'll need to try to correct this error
somehow so those are the possibilities as a point of terminology
when we refer to the distance of a stabilizer code what we mean is the minimum weight of a poly operation falls
into the second category meaning that it changes the code space in some non-trivial way but the code doesn't
detect this and when we say that a stabilizer code is an nmd stabilizer code using
double square brackets as is shown on the screen what that means is that encodings are n cubits in length the